o psol seja bem vindo a mais um vídeo e
hoje temos aqui um vídeo foi selecionado
pela loja dinheiro bege que nem viu este
robô aqui e alguns sensores os livros
produtos constar na descrição deste
vídeo e ocupam do desconto também e
minha idéia é montar primeiro robô pra
vocês verem mais ou menos como é que
olha em volta e depois mais para frente
vamos estar com fios é minha
metralhadora ainda é a entrada de pará
cinco clássicos mas como servo que o
cruzeiro é muito fraquinho
então eu sou pública e dois elásticos e
mais para frente eu quero fazer outro
vídeo fazendo uma outra versão desta
arma que disparou 5 elásticos ou mais
pra isso eu vou usar um cervo mais forte
e depois também que dar movimento à arma
ou seja a arma e ir para a direita para
a esquerda para cima e para baixo mas
por agora vamos ficar só como fui
mudando o robô
pô
pode fazer a uma primeira coisa que eu
fiz foi modular em 3d e depois imprime
usando uma impressora 3d mas eu sei que
muitos de vocês não vão ter isso em casa
e não vão saber um chico 3d
então existe uma maneira que vocês
consigam replicar está em casa
utilizando o cartão então proveitos de
picolé vocês entenderem como funciona
vai ser muito fácil fazer o mesmo
a melhor parte diz trouble e vocês não
precisam saber programar nada básico -
só tem que respeitar estes blocos para
estar e branca ea forma que vocês
colocam els andar de frente
funcionalidades ao roubo
agora se vocês quiserem programar
utilizando métodos tradicionais também
na tem várias opções de programação
isso pra mim acho que a maior parte seja
adaptada todas as pessoas desde os
iniciantes aos avançados
vou falar que vocês vão encontrar um
modelo de moedas que vocês conseguem
programar em diferentes cores pois tem
uma placa de bhutto ou seja você
consegue conectar o outro roubo a um
telemóvel ou então uma tabela e ainda
não fiz isso porque o quinto e
funcionalidade isto seja tem que sentar
botões isso eu tenho que ver depois como
é que se faz é depois tem dois sensores
que é o de luxo e depois do som ou seja
se acontecer alguma coisa por exemplo
xds baez tradisom acontece alguma coisa
no robô automaticamente ou seja dá para
programar este tipo de actividades
automáticas aí de forma externa seja
seus ternos vocês têm muita distância e
um jegue linhas pretas que ainda não
usei mas já vi vários robôs e dezembro e
então eu gosto mais de fazer coisas que
ainda não viu pessoas a fazer
ela espera usar mais tarde aí e só se
perde no estado se você tiver alguma
sugestão dá uma coisa que eu posso fazer
controlo deixe nos comentários e isso
muito obrigado até a próxima